this is a production of cornell
university
um thank you all so much for joining us
today
um so
my name is zachary stancil and i am the
current usda hemp germplasm curator
um and we are absolutely thrilled that
y'all made a little bit of time today
it's going to be special and
it'll be well worth it
so
i wanted to just
quickly tell you a little bit about our
work and why we were so excited to host
hemp 411
so my team and i
run the hemp germplasm repository in
beautiful cold snowy geneva new york
which is similar to a sea uh library but
it's a library for seeds which is really
fun
so the first goal of this work is to
protect the genetic diversity of many
different kinds of hemp from all over
the world
our second goal is to make these seeds
available for science
so these seeds kind of like a library
can be requested by plant scientists
plant breeders educators
we believe that these seeds hold answers
to
all kinds of different questions that we
would care about while studying hemp
and we hope that our work here will
allow universities companies farmers and
ultimately everyone
to benefit from the thousands of
potential uses of hemp
so during the course of this work we've
met all kinds of interesting dynamic
people from across the entire world of
hemp and we wanted to share them with
you
so we've teamed up with some of our good
friends at cornell university
to present them with you today so um
i i want to first of all thank tony
baraco who's working on my team and he's
done so much of the work for this
as well as uh george stack gemma osborne
and kim paul at cornell who have been
just awesome setting up all the
logistics
but most of all i am absolutely thrilled
to present our speaker today
so
her name is dr heather grab and she is a
senior lecturer in the school of
integrated plant science at cornell
university
so heather delivers
best practices for the cultivation and
processing of cannabis and hemp
to professionals in cornell's hemp
science program
she uses things like remote sensing
large-scale community data sets
and advanced analytical methods to
create data-driven solutions
for challenges at the interface of
natural resource conservation and
agriculture
a few things
about heather's work with hemp she is on
the european industrial hemp fiber
working group
she is on the education
committee for the global hemp
association
and she's a member of the sustainability
committee for the new york state growers
and processors association
um also in conjunction with all of that
heather is
widely known as an absolutely
outstanding teacher and mentor
for the cornell hemp mps program so i'm
gonna stop yapping and i bring you
heather grab
you zach for that kind introduction
uh thanks also to tony and george and
gemma and others who've been involved
in organizing this seminar series
it's a particular pleasure to be here to
speak with this group from all over
the world and i'm really excited also
for the participation of
our colleagues from the 1890s land grant
institutions within the u.s
a special shout out also to the asl
interpreters that are on the call today
and
providing signing i think i will
probably give them a big challenge so
you'll notice
many
difficult words to begin with on my
slide here
if you've tuned in to some of the other
sessions that have already launched
you'll know that there are
three broad market classes for hemp and
we will touch on the processing that's
involved in each of those different
market classes today so before we dive
in on that i want to give you just a bit
of background information
about myself so as
uh zach mentioned i'm a senior lecturer
in hemp science in the school of
integrative plant science here at
cornell university where i teach courses
and mentor students in our hemp science
mps program so this is a graduate degree
program it's one year
after students have finished their
bachelor's degree that helps to develop
a workforce that's ready to engage with
this rapidly growing hemp industry
before my role um within the hemp
science mps program
i completed my phd in entomology so my
academic background is really in crop
protection and particularly in the
integrated pest and pollinator
management of crop systems and i was
lucky enough to work with some students
here in our hemp program
to catalog the diversity of
some insects you might not expect to see
visiting have crops like these native
pollinators
so to give you an idea more broadly of
this program
it is a one-year
in class intensive master's degree
program
uh one of your organizers tony barracco
is an alumnus of our program and i'm so
excited that he still
is close to us here at cornell at uh the
hemp germplasm collection working with
dr zach stancil
so some of the courses that we offer
from this program that are really
tailored towards hemp and cannabis
production include the cannabis biology
society industry overview course that
gives you an idea for market trends
regulations business structures within
the industry
i teach a class called hemp production
systems in the fall semesters and then
in the spring semester students take
courses focused on breeding and genetics
as well as the chemistry and
pharmacology of cannabis and then take
another class with me that has a really
fun lab called hemp processing and that
is sort of what i'm going to give you a
sneak peek on in the slides today so
i've attempted to cover a semester's
worth of content in just one 35 to 40
minute period here so we're not going to
go too deep on any one practice but
really just give you an overview of
ideas in the industry again as i
mentioned earlier my academic background
is really as an ecologist and as a data
scientist so i'm not a chemist and i'm
not an engineer which hopefully means
that we won't get too tangled up in the
particular
terminologies or
processing efficiency equations that are
really important to the industry but the
goal today is just to give you a broad
overview
and i think one of the most important
points to think about when we are
approaching processing
is how important it is overall for the
industry so i have taken just a brief
snapshot here example for new york state
where cornell university is located
this data is
supplied by the new york state
department of ag and markets which
handles hemp production in new york
state
and
it's from our 2020 growing season
and in this season we had about 25 000
acres of a licensed hemp not all of
those acres were actually planted or
harvested but that was the amount that
was licensed
among
537 licensed growers
with about 99 licensed processors
and so using those numbers we can start
to create a picture of what the ratio of
growers to processors looks like in new
york state and this same equation with
some numbers varying is also true for
many other states across the u.s and
countries across the world so if we look
at these numbers what they tell us is
again making some assumptions around
what was planted and how much in new
york state where most of our acres are
dedicated to high cannabinoid hemp so
i've made an assumption there
we have about 28 growers for every one
processor
so if we spread those those acres evenly
among growers that means each grower has
around 50 acres of hemp that's licensed
to them
and given the ratio of growers to
processors that means we have about 250
acres of hemp production for every
licensed processor
using data that was just released in the
new usda national hemp report we now
know that average production of floral
hemp and open cultivation was around
1235
pounds per acre
meaning that every one of those hemp
processors assuming that average rate of
production across all of the acres that
they would be responsible for if divided
equally has about 300 000 pounds of
flour to process
so focusing on the processing capacity
of our cannabinoid hemp processors if we
take for example a craft processor so
really small scale production using a
supercritical co2 extraction equipment
with 20 liter capacity can probably
process around 40 pounds
per day that means it's going to take
them almost 21 years to get through that
one year supply of hemp grown
in new york state
and a little bit larger facility with a
100 liter supercritical co2 extractor
would still take about 4.2 years to get
through their
processing supply
of cannabinoid hemp
and even the ethanol extractors which
have much larger capacity so something
close to 700 pounds per day would still
take over a year to process a single
year's production within new york state
and what this highlights really is that
the producers and hopefully you you know
tuned in to hear the earlier talks on
indoor and outdoor fiber hemp and grain
hemp and high cannabinoid hemp
production
they've scaled up really rapidly but we
have not seen the same
scale and capacity of our processors so
meeting that demand is really critical
in developing the hemp industry whether
it's for cannabinoids
fiber or for grain production within the
us
so
again hopefully you are very familiar
with these different market classes of
hemp but there's a few that we will
touch on today
fiber hemp as well as hemp that is grown
for seed and grain and then also spend
some time talking about high cannabinoid
hemp for flower production as well as
some of the processes that extract
compounds that are relevant from the
flower material
and i just want to start off today
because there will be many terms that
are unfamiliar to folks with this brief
warning perhaps also for our asl
interpreters that there's going to be
some technical terms still and those
will be heavier on the fiber processing
side of things
but i don't want you to get scared and
panic or tune out we'll go slowly
through each of these terms and spend
some time
talking about the anatomical parts of
hemp and then i encourage you of course
to put your questions for
the end in the q and a
so let's start out with focusing on
fiber processing to understand fiber
processing you have to understand the
anatomy of hemp so what you can see here
is an image of a cross section of a
fiber hemp stem and then we can also see
sort of an illustrated image that will
help us to better understand the key
important parts if we work our way from
the outside in we have the epidermal
layer that's that green portion on the
outside of the stem and just inside of
that we start to hit some of the most
important parts of the stem those
primary bast fiber bundles these are the
portions that are most useful for
textile production
just interior to that
we have some smaller fiber bundles in
the plant that are called secondary
basque fiber bundles so these you'll
notice they're smaller they tend also
not to be quite as strong
and not as long so they have different
uses and applications and as a
fiber hemp plant matures
we see a higher proportion of those
secondary bass fibers compared to the
primary bass fiber bundles
inside of that we probably have our next
most important hemp fiber product that
is called the herd it's that inner wood
woody core
of the plant that we see a lot of
development in the cannabinoid hemp
fibers and also with grain hemp
cultivars that need to hold up heavy
inflorescences or inflorescences that
are full of grain but we see somewhat
less of these in cultivars that have
been bred
strongly for textile grade fiber
production so there they would actually
have much more of this hollow
inner space inside the stem of the plant
and i mentioned each one of these
products has a different set of uses so
those primary bass fiber bundles on the
outside of the plant produce that nice
spinning textile grade fiber
the secondary bass fibers tend to
produce shorter fibers called toe which
we might use for some non-woven
applications and then there's a lot of
interest in products being developed
from the herd or also you will see it
referred to as shives as well
so this slide here shows you an overview
of the process diagram for taking hemp
from
harvest so
if you heard our very first talk in the
series that covered many of the aspects
that you would need to think about for
fiber hemp production and we're going to
pick up right where that left off and
think about what happens after that crop
is harvested off the field how do we
turn it into more high value products
that are ready to go into different
products that we might want to buy
and the very first step for fiber
processing is something that's called
redding
so redding
is a step that involves either the
microbial
or the chemical breakdown of compounds
called pectin which are sticky gummy
compounds that hold together all of
those vast fiber bundles
and keep them in contact with that inner
woody core called the herd so
we want to be able to separate those
really cleanly like in this diagram here
from the plant and so breaking down the
pectins allows us to easily remove those
bath fiber bundles from the inner woody
core and there's two different ways that
this process is normally achieved so
field reading is one option and we'll
talk about that in a second but there's
also
water reading as an option for breaking
down that pectin material
so this is um some illustrations from
some scientific publications showing the
in the first panel here the microbial
community that was associated with the
reading of fiber hemp and that includes
bacteria as well as fungi and what this
study reported was actually a very large
proportion belong of this community
belonged to the proteobacteria
which is pretty stable across the
different stages of reading here where
each bar represents an individual stage
but we do see some groups that increase
in their relative abundance across
reading like the bacterioides so what
are these microbes doing to the plant
that's where this other image comes into
play here so we have the inner woody
core
represented here
and then the outside of the stem is
labeled over here that's the epidermis
and sandwiched in between these two
again we have these vast fiber bundles
so this first diagram shows us an unread
hemp stem so fresh harvested off the
field and we see all these fiber bundles
are held very tightly together
the next panel shows an
additional time step into the reading
where we start to see
some spaces beginning to emerge and then
the next two panels show an even further
reading process on these stems so at the
final stage here we see there's a lot of
separation that's starting to happen
between these vast fiber bundles and
also the inner woody core as well as the
epidermal tissue on the plant so that's
really important
that is um the microbial or field
reading process but we also see water
and tank reading being used in some
circumstances so water running in open
waterways like this is not
a
very sustainable practice because of the
action of the bacteria and the compounds
that are leaching from the stems so we
often see redding occurring in these
controlled tank environments where we
can apply different microbes or
different compounds to help to to
facilitate that redding action but it's
still not a process that's very widely
used in europe or in the us
where the much more common process we
see is field reading or do reading where
right after that
fiber is harvested it's laid down in the
fields and the natural microbes that
occur
in the environment as well as on the
stem of the plant act to break down the
pectin within the stem so there's a lot
to be learned about what the optimal
conditions are for redding across
different climates throughout the world
and that's something i hope we have more
data
on soon
so once that fiber material is ready and
we're ready to have a separation from of
the bass fiber bundles from the herd the
next step is a mechanical or physical
separation of those bath fibers from the
herd through a process called
decortication
decortication
is usually achieved by these machines
with roller so hopefully you can see the
video here this is an example of a small
scale fiber processing machine where you
can see their hand feeding i would not
recommend that anybody put their fingers
that close to a machine but you can see
what is happening here these uh rollers
are crushing the plant stem
and the inner woody core drops out from
the bottom
here
and those longer bass fibers come out
and collect at the back side of the
machine so we can see them putting these
intact hemp stems or hemp straw
into the machine and these rollers are
crushing the stems
while the curd or chives falls out the
bottom and again those long bass fibers
are coming out the back of the machine
after that material passes through the
decortication step there's two other
steps involved and these are steps that
have been adopted from
flax processing so flax is a similar
crop that's grown to produce linen and
these two steps are called scooching
and hackling so squishing
is a step that removes all those small
pieces of herd or shines as well as some
of the toe or the short
fibers from the longer vast fiber
bundles
and then hackling is the next step
that's a combing process that's used to
soften and align the fibers so the video
that i'm going to show next is one of
these small scale processing lines
that's been developed for flax but is
also
easily adapted for hemp fiber processing
so this is the skutching machine so
again that's the machine that's going to
take any of those residual
inner woody herd pieces and remove them
so they'll all be essentially scraped
off
of the stems and we also see in this
process a lot of the shorter fibers the
toe
flying off of that line
so now we're ready for the hackling step
and this is essentially again this
combing
and aligning machine
so here's what one of these small scale
machines looks like that's the fiber
that comes out at the end of the process
and we'll see it running here so it's a
series of combs that have increasingly
tighter spacing of their teeth
as we move across the processing line
so once we've finished with our
skutching and hackling we have
long spinnable hemp fibers and across
these different steps we've also
separated out some other important
products like the herd or chives as well
as the toe so short non-aligned fibers
that have many other applications and
there's a huge range of different
products that hemp fiber and hemp herds
can be incorporated into i've
highlighted just a small set of those
here but composites for example are ones
that are produced mostly using those
herd or shy
products
animal bedding is a huge use right now
within the us for herd products those
non-aligned short fibers called toe can
be incorporated into products like paper
and those longer aligned hemp fibers can
be incorporated into products like ropes
or for example textiles or other
technical products even including
batteries
so that's fiber let's spend some time
thinking about hemp grain processing
which has fewer technical sounding terms
but somewhat of a complicated process
diagram here so after we've harvested
our grain with a combine and we've
cleaned it to remove any of those
residual brats or plant material that
could potentially cause spoilage in our
grain bins we've assumed it's all dried
down the processor receives that hemp
grain and then has a lot of choices
about what to do with it so one option
if you wanted to produce a product like
hemp hearts
would be to take those whole hemp seeds
and remove the outer hull portion so
that we have those yummy ham parts and
we would put on our yogurt and that
gives us two products hemp holes which
are high in fiber as well as the high
protein hemp hearts
we might also choose to press for oil
and usually that's done from whole hemp
seeds but it can also be done
from the hulled hemp hearts and that
gives us again two products
one that's called press cake or seed
meat and another that is unrefined oil
that might go on to
specialty dressings or could be further
refined into
other products
so let's look at the steps along the way
the first is the dehulling step if we
wanted to produce hemp hearts the most
common way that we remove those hulls
from the heart is using an impact
dehuller where the whole hemp grains are
introduced through the top of this
machine here in the center and then
these paddles are spinning around at
very high speeds and they accelerate the
individual hemp grains into
the side of the equipment here and
essentially that impact of the seed
breaking into the um the side breaks the
hull and releases the heart there are
several other options that are available
to de-hull hemp seeds including bar
dehullers and roller de-haulers however
hemp does not necessarily always have
very uniform size particularly because
it's continuing to mature grain across
the season so you can use some sorting
procedures ahead of time to sort out
those very small or perhaps even
unusually large grains but impact
dehauling is a great option for hemp
seed processing because it can
accommodate some of that variability in
seed size
any of these processes though are going
to give you
a mix then of
holes together with your hearts which
nobody wants to put on their yogurt in
the morning so it's really important to
have a separation step that comes next
and there's a few options here for how
you might approach that one is to use
these table separators so these rely on
shaking of angled table tables to
separate out a mix of materials based on
differences in their weight so lighter
materials will come off one end of the
table and heavier materials will come
off another and by linking these
together in a chain or a series you
actually
can
make several different separations in
one pass
another option
that's great for small scale
is pneumatic separation or essentially
using air and gravity together
to make that separation based on the
size and the surface area of a mixed set
of objects so here these brown points
would represent the heavier hearts and
blue points would represent the lighter
holes coming off of your de-hauling line
and entering into your separator and
those heavy hearts and holes drop down
from your hopper and are introduced into
this chamber where there's a strong flow
of air coming through the machine
that air will blow
the lighter material with a larger
surface area off into a second chamber
where the heavier material will collect
in a different one so there we are
achieving that separation
so i mentioned earlier that you might
want to take those parts
and press them but again frequently
growers and processors are
choosing to put whole hemp seeds
into the next step for
oil expelling in this case so having
those holes on can help to increase the
friction and the amount of oil that you
are able to press out and most
processors are using screw presses
at cold conditions which isn't
necessarily cold but they're it's sort
of warm it's below the threshold for a
cold pressed seed oil
and so we start out with introducing
seeds into the hopper and then inside of
the barrel of a screw press we have our
expeller screw so this has increasingly
tight spacing and it's rotating
across the barrel's length
at the end of the barrel there's these
pores that allow the oil
that is pressed out under pressure to
be released from the channel
and then all the rest of that product is
uh extruded
through the nozzle at the end of the
machine and i'm going to show you a
video of what that process looks like at
small scale so this is a hemp seed oil
press from a german company here you can
see
those pores in the barrel where the oil
is able to come out they have a
temperature probe here monitoring the
temperature of that oil to ensure that
it is within cold press standards
because the pressure generated within
that barrel and the friction can
actually raise the temperature overall
we can change the speed of these
machines depending on the attributes of
those hemp grain feedstocks that are
going in or to try to control the
temperature of the machine
and then here at the end you see the
press cake that's coming out so that is
rich in all of those holes and also
protein
that was not
extruded in the oil portion
so again that's the overview of hemp
grain processing going from cleaned and
dried whole hemp grains through
dehulling and then also through oil
pressing where we end up with that seed
cake or seed meal
which can be very high in fiber as well
as protein
to unrefined oil or even refined oils
and these are used in a wide range of
different products so i'm seeing a lot
of beauty and personal care products and
stores within the us that are starting
to incorporate hemp seed oils for its
beneficial properties
as well as hemp seed oil supplements and
it's really important to distinguish
that kind of product from
what other products that may be labeled
as hemp oil extracts that are actually
more for the cannabinoid composition of
that product whereas a hemp seed oil
should not have cannabinoids present in
it
we also see
a big a wide range of different food
products
the specialty hemp seed oils
hemp hearts i mentioned earlier as well
as that hemp protein
which is derived from the press cake
when it's ground up and separated out
through some sifting steps there's a a
number of new and innovative products
i'm excited about so it was really cool
to see folks that are including um hemp
grain as part of the mash and their
distilled products like this one here
and of course hemp for many many years
has been included
as both a pet bird food and a wild bird
food ingredient but we're starting to
see a lot more research and hopefully
we'll soon see the adoption of hemp
grain as livestock and poultry feeds
within the u.s
so on to our
last step of fi of the flower processing
so here there's a few different options
but the very first and most important
thing after harvest is to make sure that
you are stabilizing your product and
that can be achieved in a number of ways
one option is by drying that flower
right away while it's still on the stem
another option that i see a lot of
producers use using is freezing their
product
that flower material um when it's
removed from the stem through this
process called bucking which you can do
either after the material is dry or even
when it's fresh and wet
can then be trimmed for smokeable
hempflower products or it may go through
some milling processes to reduce the
size of the flour so that it can be
incorporated into other products like
pre-rolls or
to increase the efficiency of extraction
processes
so let's take a look at what drying
looks like in practice there's a lot of
growers
who choose to dry their hemp biomass or
their hemp flower material in protected
sort of temporary areas like these coupe
houses here so in one case we have
a barrier on the ground which is great
for helping to mitigate any humidity
that may be coming up or vapors that are
coming up from the ground in this case
we have a grower who's hanging hemp in a
hoop house that has open ends and also
an open floor which means that they
might you know need to be thinking very
carefully about outdoor weather
conditions and managing the humidity in
that environment because what we do not
want to see is any of those post-harvest
microbes that can destroy crops and can
also cause potentially some unhealthy
conditions
in the products that are produced from
them so many growers especially for high
value crops have
come to develop these much more
controlled conditions indoor where we
can monitor air flow we can monitor
humidity and temperature very carefully
within the crop one thing you'll also
notice here in this example
is that the plants have been broken down
to individual branches so that there's a
lot more uniformity in the drying area
compared to the last slide i showed
where the interior of the plant here
may have a much higher level of humidity
and again therefore potentially
susceptible to microbial growth within
that region
so here they've break in they've broken
the plant down into
individual branches and they've also
removed a lot of those big broad fan
leaves from the plants to help to
facilitate that drying process
growers that are
and processors that are
doing really large scale processing
might also choose to use some of these
faster higher heat technologies so in
this case this is an example of a forage
dryer that's being used to quickly dry
down a large volume of already
milled hemp flour here so these
processes are very fast they can dry out
your plant very fast but they also may
come at the cost of losing some of those
valuable compounds like terpenes that
are quite valuable
in response to that growers have started
to explore other technologies like
freeze dryers there's some very large
scale freeze dryer products that are on
the market now that operate under a
vacuum but at very very low temperatures
in order to sublimate the water off of
the flower and they give you a very well
preserved very good color flower product
coming out of these
so in terms of removing those flowers
from the stem this is an example of what
a bucking room might look like where
we're removing those
inflorescences from the stem that
they've been dried on this is an
incredibly labor-intensive process and
so can cost a large amount of money if
you need to employ a staff to process
large volumes of hemp flour and in
response to that the industry has been
introducing several innovative products
one that i will show you here is one of
these automated bucking machines so here
you can see they're introducing the stem
and it's automatically stripping off all
of the flower material from the stem
using these two rollers here to make
that separation so these machines can be
used on dry
or on
fresh or wet hemp material so this is
just a snapshot of what that looked like
for this particular product from munch
machines called the mother bucker it has
two rollers that grab onto the stem
but then a hole that makes it so only
the stem can go through and none of the
flower material which is left behind
so for those processors that want to
produce a product for pre-rolls or for
extract one of the next steps in the
process before we dive into the
extraction itself is size reduction so
they might choose to use a machine like
the knife mill that's pictured here that
chops up that flower to a very
particular size so that we can optimize
the efficiency of our extracts and so
again just to leave you with a picture
of what this overall process looks like
before we continue on and dive in on
this extract portion of the talk
so in extracts for high cannabinoid
products there's a range of different
options and technologies that are
available they broadly fall into two
classes those that are based on solvents
and those that are solvent free and
based on mechanical separation so
beginning with those solvent-based
processes i'll give you a process
diagram for each one of these and then
briefly touch on the pros and cons for
each of them
so we'll start out with the the highest
throughput example which is an ethanol
based solvent extraction so these can be
operated at relatively high volumes
and ethanol is a compound that is
generally considered as a safe product
to keep around which allows us to use it
at high capacity this is the same
ethanol but a very high proof as what we
might find in alcoholic beverages
so we have a large ethanol storage tank
area
for optimal extraction conditions these
pieces of equipment and systems are
operated at extremely cold temperatures
and the reason for that is that room
temperature ethanol has very low
specificity
as a solvent which means it's not only
going to extract the cannabinoids and
terpenes and other compounds you might
want but it's also going to co-extract
many other compounds like chlorophyll
which gives the plants their green color
or some of the waxes that are structural
in those plants that would need to be
cleaned up in post-processing so some of
that process can be optimized by keeping
your ethanol extraction temperatures
extremely cold
so those cooled ethanol
storage areas will come into again a
chilled extraction vessel i'm also
seeing a lot of centrifuge type systems
that spin the ethanol kind of like a
washing machine would spin it in order
to get all of that ethanol removed from
the flower material that's in here when
we're finished with our process
and then these come into a collection
station
and importantly the solvent the
ethnologist case needs to be removed
from the product so here's one example
of a post-processing piece of equipment
called a rotary evaporator or rotovap
which uses the difference in the boiling
point of ethanol versus the boiling
points of the compounds of interest like
cannabinoids for example
which so cannabinoids have a much lower
or sorry much higher boiling point than
ethanol does so you can set a a hot
water bath and submerge this globe with
your extract into it you can set that at
a temperature that is higher than the
boiling point of your ethanol but lower
than the boiling point of your
cannabinoids so that the ethanol boils
off and is collected you can also do
this under vacuum to reduce those
boiling points and use less energy
that's reca the ethanol is recollected
and reintroduced into the system
leaving you with your more concentrated
hemp extract at the end
so hydrocarbons are one that are
increasing in popularity
a pro to these systems is that they have
much higher
specificity compared to ethanol they're
also very fast in their extraction a con
to these systems though is that they
are
of course prone potentially to explosion
when systems are not well engineered so
of course butane is a really common
example of a hydrocarbon that's used in
these systems and there are strict
regulatory limits about how much butane
processing facilities can keep on hand
and so that sets an upper limit on the
overall capacity of hydrocarbon
extractors but for craft extractors
they're a really great solution because
of that high specificity so usually we
will keep a reservoir under pressure
of our solvent like
butane for example that will move in the
liquid phase because it's under pressure
into our extraction column where our
hemp flour material
is it comes out of this column and then
through a series of reduced pressure
steps we can first drop out some of the
waxes that may have been
co-extracted and then finally
collect out those cannabinoids and
terpene
molecules and then re-send that
solvent back into the system so this is
a closed loop system
which many jurisdictions are now
requiring processors who use these
technologies to use
one that is very popular and generally
considered
safe as well is a supercritical fluid
extractor so here we're not using any
explosive or flammable solvents we're
simply using co2 under high pressure the
safety precaution here though is that
this is under extremely high pressures
so these systems need to be very well
engineered and in this case we take co2
which is normally a gas and we exert a
lot of pressure and also cold
temperatures to bring that co2 to its
super critical point so this point where
it's got properties of both a liquid and
a gas and by very precisely controlling
the parameters so the density of that
supercritical fluid we can make very
high specificity
extracts using supercritical co2
extractors
the other benefit of these systems is
because they're using co2 as their
solvent that goes back into the
atmosphere and we don't need to worry
about potential contamination of
residual solvents in the system
the con to these systems in addition to
operating at very high pressures
is
that they're sort of slow and their
overall capacity is somewhat low for
that reason so here we take that
highly pressurized supercritical co2 and
we introduce it into our extraction
vessel here and it spends several hours
interacting
with the hemp flower that's in that
column
and then moves into these separate
separation stage that has the graduated
decrease in pressure in the system until
you're left finally with your last
fraction
including things like cannabinoids and
that co2 can then be cycled back and
re-introduced into the system
one of the
lowest tech
solvent-based options
is a classic oil infusion and there's
several platforms or technologies that
have thought about bringing this up to a
much more industrial scale
but simply put these um use an oil so
something like olive oil for example you
could also use mct oil or even hemp seed
oil in order to extract those lipophilic
cannabinoid compounds that means they
like fats and they'll move into
the oil
with the addition of heat as a source so
this is sort of a very
low tech option
but potentially depending on how high
this temperature gets you might not
necessarily meet the safety requirements
to kill any microbes that could be
contaminating your extract
so i know we're running out low on time
here so i want to move through these
other
solvent free options that use mechanical
force
to separate trichomes from the plant
material one of them that's also
relatively low-tech is a
rosin press so these take
hemp flour
or
the ice water hash products or other
trichomes that have been separated and
press them at high pressure and with
heat between two metal plates
and
the
cannabinoids and terpenes will flow off
of these plates
so you could start out with this
hemp flower that's gone through an ice
water extraction so products that come
out of this are generally referred to as
ice water hash or bubble hash here's an
example of a large scale option for this
mechanical separation but hemp flour
that's frozen is introduced into this
ice water bath so that it is maintained
at a cold temperature and then agitated
either by hand with paddles or through
some mechanical process
and then there's a set of filters that
will separate out the plant material
from those small little trichome heads
which you would be left with at the end
so finally
independent of whatever extraction
method you may have applied upstream
there's several additional refinement
steps that you could apply
starting with crude oil which is so in
this you know highest unrefined class
that's closest to what was represented
in the plant that it was extracted from
this contains a full spectrum of
different compounds that we want but it
may also contain a lot of compounds that
were co-extracted that we do not want
like the chlorophylls and waxes i
mentioned earlier you could further
refine that product using filters for
example charcoal filters are a great a
great option as well as a process called
winterization which subjects your
extract to some very cold temperatures
that precipitate out the waxes from the
solution and you might also at this
stage choose to go through some
decarboxylation
steps that take the cannabinoids from
the acidic form that they're found
primarily in the plant into their
neutral forms
you could further refine your product
into a distillate using either a short
path distillation which operates on on
principles that are very similar to the
rotovap i showed you earlier or through
a white film or falling film
distillation apparatus and then finally
we get our most refined products so
these contain a narrow spectrum or even
a single cannabinoid or terpene compound
at very very high purity and these are
isolated through
chromatography practices and then
through crystallization of those
products so i think i've taken up a
bunch of time talking and i really want
to make sure that we have time to get to
our questions for today so i will leave
it here at that slide and um
feel free i guess tony or george to go
ahead and start shooting questions from
the audience at me
yeah awesome great great talk heather um
so we have lots of questions in the chat
we'll try to get to as many as we can
um
taj starr asks
do you have any experience with using
the hemp train as a processor are there
any caveats thank you so the hemp train
for those who are not in the fiber world
is one of those um decortication
platforms but also offers a lot of the
separation of those um smaller fragments
like the toe as well as the herd and
even separating your herd into different
grades so tiny dust herd versus larger
herd that might be suitable for hemp
create for example
i do not personally have any experience
working with a hemp train but there are
um several in operation one of which i
think is in lancaster county
pennsylvania not too far from us here so
i'm excited to to potentially get the
chance to see that in action
great
um
another question uh
from don
um
are the hemp grant
separators available if so uh what would
be the nominal costs
there are so separators in terms of like
the impacty huddlers or table separators
the brand that we use is fosberg in our
at our agritech campus
in geneva new york uh where tony zack
and george are located we have a full
grain processing line from forsberg
there i do not know off the top of my
head exactly the numbers but the nice
thing also is that these are fairly
customizable lines where each piece of
equipment can be purchased separately
and built up and i know there are even
folks in the industry who are using
those same pieces of equipment you would
use for grain processing to do some
sorting of material that comes out of
fiber decoration as well
great uh another question from mary
erlina
asks grain processing questions is the
equipment fairly standard if you are
already a grain farmer slash grain
processor or is there special equipment
required for him
that's an excellent question and i think
it speaks to a broader trend within the
industry so the same equipment that you
would
use to process other oil seeds can be
fairly easily adapted to process hemp
grain which is why we've seen much less
of a bottleneck in ramping up hemp grain
production compared to hemp fiber
production where sure we can sort of
adapt some of the flax processing
equipment but
there's not much of that in the us to
begin with
and there's still a whole suite of other
optimization steps that we need for
fiber processing so i would say those
who are using a
screw press to process other oil seed
crops would very easily be able to do a
little bit of process optimization
and to produce some really nice quality
hemp seed oil
awesome uh dr sarah eichler asks is
there more than pectinases at work with
fiber redding do synthetic pectinases
facilitate controlled redding that is an
excellent question there are surely many
other
compounds in addition to pectinases so
pectinases are enzymes that break down
pectin there are other compounds that
might contribute to the breakdown of
lignin as well
and
there's a lot of active research going
on right now in
microbes that may produce some of these
interesting compounds that facilitate
redding as well as enzymes that we could
just add to controlled reading
environments to optimize the quality of
the fiber material that's being produced
fantastic um
question from gary fish asks how safe is
ethanol in regards to flammability and
worker exposure is an ethanol in known
carcinogen
so
ethanol is um certainly flammable but
unlike hydrocarbons it's not explosive
or extremely volatile so that does
increase the safety
there
i'm sure there
have been studies that have linked
ethanol to carcinogenic activity
particularly through prolonged exposure
over time so it is really important when
you are working with an equipment
supplier to make sure that they have the
appropriate process controls in place to
safely handle something like ethanol so
it's considered safe in terms of like
the threshold for allowing those
residual solvents into products is
relatively high we consume ethanol in
beverages it's added to pharmaceutical
products and it's you know can be found
in many other things so it's safer than
hydrocarbons but there are of course
long-term exposure considerations and
and flammability that do need to be
taken into
account uh great uh another question
from joy
uh asks besides chlorophyll and fats and
waxes what else is extracted at room
temperature or up to 60 degrees c
ethanol ethanol extraction
that is an excellent question um there
are also many other compounds of
interest in hemp
including some flavonoids that could
also be extracted using ethanol
it's possible also that you might
co-extract some sugars as well from the
plant during that ethanol extraction
which is again why we would want to
reduce the temperature of our ethanol
extractions if what we want to target is
the cannabinoids
um
a question from don asks
do all hemp grain food products have
gras generally recognized as safe status
from fda
and livestock feed status from usda
so
for human consumption
there's a lot more that is permitted of
course there's always safety
considerations in terms of
mycotoxins and microbes that may be
contaminating grain products but we've
allowed hemp grain products
like the ones i showed you earlier
including the pressed hemp seed oils
cake which can be processed into protein
powders
and the hemp hearts for human
consumption those are all considered as
appropriate food ingredients and
generally recognized as safe
the same is not true for livestock so
there's a separate body that regulates
the ingredients that can go into
livestock and poultry and make sure that
they're safe for the animals as well as
say for the consumers that are
going to be purchasing those products
and
you know i know those agencies are
actively engaged with the hemp industry
right now and working through the
process of the research that needs to be
conducted to make sure that we are
ensuring the safety of those products so
i'm hoping very soon we will have
hemp grain and hemp press cake available
to
feed to livestock because i think that's
a really important development overall
in the hemp grain market to be able to
have access to that you know on the off
chance that you're not able to send your
material to
a human food processor that you could
divert that and have the secondary
market available to you or a secondary
market for the byproducts like the press
cake that's in that's
produced in hemp oil production
awesome um there has been a few
questions about your very first
infographic that you showed about new
york and uh basically asking the ratio
how was the layout of processors and
growers is it mainly cannabinoids fiber
grain what is the outlook on that
so in new york state um very early on in
the adoption of hemp by
again markets through our
hemp research licensing program we did
have a lot of production of fiber and
grain across the state but subsequently
as licenses became available to more
folks within the industry we saw high
cannabinoid hemp really take over a lot
of the acres within the state so within
the northeast that's our predominant
crop that we grow
so i'm hoping that we will see the
introduction of more grain and fiber
within the state as our processing
capacity is able to
spool up as well
awesome fantastic uh heather but i think
that's all the time we have for
questions so i just wanted to
thank dr grab once again i feel like she
got uh
several months of lectures crammed into
an hour and answered questions we had so
many today um
and we're so grateful for her i also
want to thank um pam and chris for
translation or interpreting today
that's much appreciated and i really
want to give a shout out to our
friends and collaborators at the 1890
institution so thank you all all so much
and we'll see you in two weeks
thanks to everyone if there are any
questions that we didn't have time to
address please feel free to get in touch
with me at my email or linkedin or other
forms it was such a pleasure to be here
to talk with you today
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu